une blonde au brushing parfait à la
tenue impeccable en talons aiguilles et
aux mensurations irréaliste pote doute
ses barbies celle qui fête ses 60 ans en
est l'incarnation de la femme objet pour
certains est au contraire une des
premières féministes pour d'autres alors
barbie 60 ans et féministe à sa création
le 9 mars 1959
c'est une petite révolution une poupée
pour les enfants mais pas pour jouer à
la maman nom barbie est une femme avec
des formes mondial david on se ressemble
beaucoup à une poupée avant les bras ils
se ressemblaient à des bébés à des
poupons et ça ça ressemble à quoi elles
mêmes tâches
barbie a une plastique parfaite mais
elle est indépendante elle a marché sur
la lune avant neil amstrong et en 1992
elle était candidate à l'élection
présidentielle des états unis au delà de
la blonde aux mensurations de mannequin
elle pourrait donc être un modèle pour
les enfants selon cette psychanalyste
faucher que la jeune fille sache qu'elle
sera pas forcément mer et puis qu'il n'y
a pas que la maternité pour les femmes
qu'il ya aussi le travail parce que
barbie va au travail
malgré ces arguments d'indépendance les
féministes ont toujours une dent contre
barbie car si la poupée a changé de
visage à plusieurs couleurs de peau et
de cheveux elle a toujours cette taille
de guêpe et ses jambes interminables
il faudra attendre 2016 soit 57 ans
après sa création pour que barbie et des
mensurations humaine voilà les nouvelles
barbie commercialisée en trois versions
aux états unis la petite la grande
la pulpeuse décliné en 7 couleurs de
peau des poupées plus réalistes à
l'image de la société
un événement salué comme une petite
révolution par le magazine time
la même année paris consacré une
exposition à la poupée et cette
contradiction femme-objet femme
indépendante et est expliquée par la
commissaire on la voit comme une blonde
à s'être occupé par son apparence alors
que mardi à l'origine c'est un jouet
vraiment d'avant-garde c'est un jeu
presque féministe qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent à la petite fille des modèles
d'identification autour de femmes qui
travaillent autour de femmes qui sortent
du schéma classique de la mer et de
l'épousant mateille continue de
bousculer les codes de la blonde aux
grands yeux bleus avec la collection
chez rose des barbies dédié aux femmes
célèbres dont l'escrimeuse ipte sillage
mohammad première barbie voilée en 2010
cet acte politique avec des convictions
idéologiques et coup marketing
seul barbie connaît la vérité
[Musique]